the u.s has announced new sanctions
against russia for what the white house
says
is the kremlin's election interference
and cyber attacks
the measures include wider restrictions
on u.s banks trading in russian debt
and the expulsion of 10 diplomats in
brussels nato announced that it supports
any u.s
actions to contain russia's
destabilizing activities
russia's foreign ministry says that a
response to the sanctions is
inevitable that it summoned the u.s
ambassador in
moscow more now from
russia shortly but first here's our
state department correspondent rosalyn
jordan in washington
this is of course uh with the expulsion
of ten
diplomats assigned to the embassy here
in washington that certainly is going to
get the headlines but this is also a
matter of the biden administration's
efforts
to hold moscow accountable for things
such as
allegedly paying bounties for uh
enemy combatants to target u.s forces
in afghanistan this also is a matter of
trying to hobble moscow's ability to uh
pay for
its uh uh its operations by
forbidding us financial institutions
from doing any business that uses the
russian ruble
as of the basis of the transaction
from mid-june and that's a considerable
financial penalty because it it sharply
limits
moscow's ability to uh do business in
international monetary markets there's
also uh the
call for more uh concern
about alexi navalny the opposition
figure who is said to be in declining
health
in a russian prison and you're seeing
more uh efforts being launched
against uh the government for its uh
ongoing uh
punishment and persecution of alexi
navalny
and there's also uh financial uh
penalties and sanctions
for uh those involved in the solar winds
uh
cyber attack against uh u.s uh computer
networks live now to al jazeera's bonnet
smith who's uh in moscow what else have
the russians been saying about this
bernard
well in the last few minutes adrian uh
maria zakharova the foreign ministry
spokeswoman
here uh in moscow in her weekly uh
meeting weekly audience with the press
she said uh that what
the sanctions the u.s have announced do
not meet the interests
of two nuclear powers the actions show
the opposite tone to the phone call to
the phone call made
between president biden who initiated
that phone call on tuesday night
and uh vladimir putin she says
that the sanctions are basis in
substance and senseless
in form and our response is inevitable
it's coming she says
the u.s ambassador's already been
summoned to the foreign ministry he's
apparently there they say
and this foreign minister spokeswoman
says he won't be getting
an easy ride but the issue is that the
us has a
long list of complaints that you heard
roslyn refer to there
against uh russia about solarwinds hack
that targeted nine federal
uh organizations in the us plus 100
companies the biggest
and most sophisticated cyber attack the
world's ever seen according to microsoft
it refers to the occupation continued
occupation of crimea
and the repression in crimea and the
jailing of alexander navalny so
all of that long list of complaints is
why the u.s says it's now taken this
action
so what if any economic impacts are
likely from
these new sanctions bernard
well one interesting indicator is that
before the detail of these
sanctions were announced the russian
ruble dropped
in value against the dollar but after
the sanctions were announced the ruble
regained what it had lost against the
dollar and this is because although
the us is stopping the buying of russian
debt
on the foot on the primary bonds market
you'll still be able to buy it
on the secondary market that means that
someone else who buy another organ
another country
or another organization that buys that
debt russia will still be able to buy it
people will still be able to buy russian
debt on the secondary market so
the economic effect is not as
significant as the markets first
feared but there are effects of course
on those individuals and those companies
that have been sanctioned
al jazeera's bonnet smith reporting live
there from moscow but at many thanks
indeed